hi premier we recently heard from dr
moore and it sounded like he was uh
getting ready to recommend that the
april 27th date for mask mandates in
places like this hospitals long-term
care
be extended past april 27th is that
something you're considering would you
look at doing that
i wouldn't have any problem at all with
that i really really wouldn't we want to
protect the most vulnerable i've always
said that from from day one but i'll
wait for dr moore to give us the
recommendations like i have right from
day one and if he gives us that right
recommendations i'd be more than happy
to to do that but most importantly we
have to take care of the most vulnerable
that's why we're giving the fourth doses
out that's why we have the antiviral
pills for the most vulnerable
and in the capacity and the hospitals
are strong right now i want to give a
shout out to all the healthcare workers
they've been absolutely
fabulous they're
they're game changers if we didn't have
the quality of health care people in
this province throughout this pandemic
we would be in deep trouble hearing some
positive information about the
wastewater test
it kind of peaked and it's slowly going
down but
i i truly believe everyone should
continue to be cautious
move forward cautiously and we've built
up the hospital capacity we're listening
to dr moore's recommendations but this
is an example of building the hospital
capacity right here in scarborough and
across the the province adding uh 8 700
new health care workers adding 3 100 new
beds
uh we're we're prepared but uh thank
goodness we're seeing
a little bit of a you know
direction going down
well first of all you know if we had to
push the maximum i'm going to handle my
minister of health but if if we need to
max it right out
we can go uh as high as i believe close
to 3000 if we had to but we aren't in
that position right now we're actually
seeing positive results uh right now
with the wastewater and let's just hope
it it goes down and we're going to be
very very cautious
and
that's what we're going to take the
approach moving forward but i'll pass it
over to the minister of health however
with the increase in the number of beds
that we've created the 3 100 beds that
we opened up several years ago that
remain in operation with the staff
that's been trained and
with the rest of the work that's
happening we are sure that we will be
able to handle any increases we saw a
huge surge during the third wave we will
be able to handle the numbers both in
terms of med surg beds as well as
intensive care beds ahead of easter long
weekend uh what's your advice to
ontarians should they avoid gatherings
are you going to be gathering with
family yourself
well i'd say uh stay cautious right stay
cautious if
you're having 15
people over
put your mask on right like it doesn't
hurt if you're in a crowded room just
like we've been through this
for two years now
it's common sense prevails
right put a mask on
doesn't it doesn't hurt
that's going to be up to each individual
person